Hello everybody!
Okay, sorry.
I'm waiting for the coffee to kick in.
I just chugged down some coffee.
I'm waiting for it to kick in.
Oh my god.
Today's gonna be...
a very long day.
Because after...
after... after the stream...
I gotta go to the bank and be an adult.
I didn't have to walk to the supermarket today.
Why can't the bank be closed?
You know, okay.
Not gonna lie.
If the bank was at least 10 minutes closer...
I wouldn't complain.
If the bank was at least 10 minutes closer.
And then you guys are like, yeah, but if you drive...
if you drive, Doki...
then it would be 10 minutes closer.
No, guys.
I can't.
I'm like already like super...
I'm already an incredibly anxious person.
And you... you saw me drive in video games.
You saw how angry I can get in video games when I'm driving.
Like, I don't... I don't wanna unleash that in the world.
I don't... I don't wanna...
I don't wanna unleash that into the world.
So, I haven't licensed.
I just haven't drove in a very long time.
I just... I wish the bank was 10 minutes closer.
Like, I don't mind dealing with bank stuff.
I just... I just wish it was 10 minutes closer.
Like, walking all the way there is just the problem.
It's just so far.
It's so fucking far.
You can't know.
No, I have to...
I have to figure out what the fuck is my routing and transit number.
And, like, I need to get...
Like, I need to...
Apparently, I need to change my address on my account, too.
And everything.
And the lady was like, Yeah, you gotta...
You gotta...
You gotta, like, uh...
Go to your branch to do all that.
Uh, driving makes me anxious, too.
I feel you.
Maybe it's worth the Uber.
It's...
It's not worth the Uber.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's...
I already spent too much on Uber Eats.
Uber doesn't need more of my money.
Like...
It doesn't...
I'm just like...
I just like...
They already have, like, majority of my income via Uber Eats.
Like, they don't need more.
They don't need...
No bicycle.
I'm, like, actually really scared of riding a bike, um...
On the road.
Um...
I...
You are rich.
Why not Uber?
You see, there's things called taxes.
There's things called tax breaks.
You know what?
You see, I...
You see, I live in a...
I live in a country where, um, health care is considered free.
And...
But...
Do you know what pays for that health care?
And...
So...
.
People...
Me...
.
So...
I gotta get injured to my day off.
To capitalize on the... on the free health care.
Anyway, yeah.
So today's gonna be an incredibly long day for me.
Is she okay?
No, it's cup being adult.
You know, like, okay, you're not adult yet.
If you're like a teenager or a tween, but that's it.
That's... that's all the ages.
Because if you're under 13, you're not supposed to be watching me.
If you're a tween and teenager, and you're not an adult yet, and you think adults have it together, we do not.
We pretend we have it together, but we're all fucking liars.
Even your parents are liars.
They don't know what they're fucking doing.
Yeah, I'm PG-13.
They're just experimenting.
You're like their... their science experiment.
They're guinea pig.
You think they have it together?
They don't.
Anyway.
I'm just more transparent than the other adults.
Stop giving away the secrets, Doki.
They're supposed to respect us.
Alright, kids today, they don't fucking respect shit.
Don't lie to yourself.
Maybe 20 years ago, they would respect adults.
But that's a lie now.
They don't respect adults anymore.
So why should I respect them?
Why?
Make it till you make it.
It's cause 20 years ago, kids didn't really have the internet.
To like know what the fuck is going on in the world.
Now kids do, and now they don't respect us.
It's not...
I felt like I was lied to.
I thought when I was an adult, I'd be respected just like how I respected adults when I was a kid.
And now all these kids know about the internet and think they're better than me.
Well, you're right.
I'm an anime girl on the internet.
You're fucking right.
This is so goddamn true.
Anyway.
Snooks, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This is so real, Doki.
I've lived in one place for two years and I'm still scared of calling my landlord.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Snooks.
Doki, please keep it together.
And please, we need them to start respecting us again.
Johnny, look on.
Thank you for the 10 gifted shows.
Thank you.
Doki's yelling at the clowns moment.
Anyway.
I'm having a midlife crisis right now.
So I'm going to start a card shop.
I heard this game is like incredibly addicting.
But I didn't really got...
I didn't get addicted to supermarket simulators.
So like...
I think it's also addicting for those who like to open card packs, I guess.
So luckily, I'm not cursed with that.
Okay, disabled controller.
If I disable controller, does that mean I'll go back to...
Okay, there we go.
What the fuck?
What is the sensitivity?
All right.
Okay.
So this is basically for those who don't know.
For those who don't know what TCG simulator, chart shop simulator is.
It's basically a card shop simulator.
It's like a supermarket simulator, but for cards.
Like literally the same thing.
I quit my day job to open my own card game shop.
This is it.
Time to get down to...
Oh, this is...
Oh, this is not 2010, boy.
Like comic book stores.
Are closing right now.
I don't think opening a TC...
Not a scam.
Not rigged.
100%.
There we go.
It's not...
It's not a great idea, but like that's what midlife crisis are for.
Open phone and stock up on cards.
Okay.
I trust it.
It's a little bit of bad timing.
Not gonna lie.
Open stock up on card packs.
Okay.
Stock order.
Oh, shit.
The newest Terramon dual master.
Oh, my God.
Only 56.96 cents.
What the fuck is the .96?
Okay.
We'll buy one pack.
For now.
We'll just...
We'll just buy one pack.
How much money do I have?
Anyway.
I have $938.
That's my entire savings right there.
Okay.
That's...
It's not great, but like...
It's...
It's not the best, but like that's okay.
Okay.
Open box.
How do I place it?
Okay.
Oh.
Nope.
How do I place this?
Oh.
Hold item.
Okay.
All right, guys.
Here it is.
My entire savings right here.
All right.
Let's see.
How much should I price that?
It is $1.
Guys, I'm going to sell it for $3 because every pack in there is a guarantee holo.
Let customers know.
All right.
We're open.
It's not rigged.
So, you'll know every cart in there is a guarantee holo right here.
Oh, yes.
See?
He knows.
Oh, my God.
Look at how many packs he bought.
Oh, market price is $3 higher?
What the fuck do you mean?
Oh, no.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
0.05.
There we go.
There you go.
Okay.
No one...
Guys, I think I almost got scammed.
Guys, I...
I think I almost...
Oh, thank God.
Oh, no.
How do I...
Okay.
Done.
I almost got scammed.
Oh, my God.
No wonder they bought so much.
I was like, whoa!
They bought...
I almost scammed myself.
Okay.
Nice.
That's okay.
We're fine.
Everything is fine.
I almost scammed myself, but I didn't.
There we go.
Okay.
See?
We're making money.
You know what?
Okay.
Since every pack is a guaranteed holo, I might as well...
No.
Maybe like...
Okay.
Maybe...
You know...
Every pack is a guaranteed holo.
So, like, you know...
Okay.
So, anyway.
Some people were asking...
Some people were asking about the weighing thing.
So, there was...
There are people...
Apparently, you can still do it, but some Pokemon cards...
I think, like, Pokemon card holos are heavier.
God!
So expensive!
Every pack is a...
You cannot...
You cannot complain!
What if you get a holo?
What?
Oh, it's so expensive, yet you bought fucking five!
You bought five of them!
That's right.
All you do is complain.
Give me my fucking money.
Anyway...
He's addicted.
He can't help it.
That's fucking right.
You'll always come back.
Okay.
I got card.
I got card and open them.
Oh, I can just open my own cards?
Wait!
Really?
Oh, my God.
Okay, there's Nimbus.
Negate 50%.
There's Tetron.
There's Chiron.
There's Clawop.
Guaranteed holo.
What can I say?
Guarant...
I...
Not rigged.
One.
I told you.
Not rigged.
None of you believe me.
I told you.
I told you my packs have guaranteed hollows.
I'm blocking the card prices.
Don't worry, I'll tell you the card price.
I'll take a hundred packs right now.
I told you guys.
You didn't believe me.
No, I'll do it again.
All right.
Watch this.
Okay.
Stop.
What can I say?
Another guaranteed hollow.
Right there.
What can I say?
It's just that easy.
It really is.
It really is that easy.
All right.
Here we go again.
What can I say?
Nines... nine point seventy-four.
I told you I'd even bring out my scale.
Look at that.
I opened three packs.
I got the gold edition.
What can I say?
I told you, my shop is not rigged.
It's not rigged!
How can it be rigged?
Oh, I don't have anything to buy right now.
Give me a sec.
Okay, we'll buy another pack here.
Purchase.
Okay, and then what do I need?
Upgrade shop?
How do I upgrade shop?
Reach shop?
Oh, reach shop level.
Okay, here we go.
Alright.
Just put more here.
You're just jealous because I have a better card shop than you.
You're jealous because you know you should have bought from my store instead of ordering online.
Yeah, I ordered online, but everything I order is gold.
Look at that.
$4.48, $5.92, and a $9.74.
Look at this.
$4.48.
First edition for you.
Look at that.
The third pack I opened.
You wish you were me.
I have the magic touch.
Alright, see?
They all heard.
They all heard about the magic of my store.
I'm making an investment.
I'm going to open another one.
Watch this.
Open pack.
That easy.
Did you guys hear the word of the magic of the store?
Did you all banter?
Somebody said...
Stop it, please.
Did you all hear?
Did you all stop taking all of them?
Hear the beauty of my shop?
Buy a table and put it in the shop?
Why do I want them to loiter?
I don't want them to loiter.
You're just here to buy the cards and leave.
Okay, we'll put it...
What if I just put it...
I'll put it here.
For atmosphere.
What are they going to do?
They're just going to play cards?
To bring their own cards in my store?
How dare they?
They're not even buying these cards from my store.
Billy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Tokyo, are you rubbing the cards like Steven Chao and the God of Gambling?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Candy, thank you for the super chat.
Tokyo, please.
I own $150 magic to gathering card.
So get that.
That $9 weak sauce out of here.
Look, Magic the Gathering had fucking years, decades to build popularity, increase in value, tear- I'll just say it.
Tetra- is it Tetramon?
Tetramon?
Tetra- Tetramon just came out last week, guys.
It doesn't have a legacy yet.
I didn't even know its existence until like today.
Okay.
It doesn't- it just came out last week.
It doesn't have a legacy yet.
Alright.
In 20 years, my $9 card is gonna be like 50- no, I'm just- no, maybe $30.
My $9 card will be $30.
This isn't accurate.
The butt crack's not showing.
Oh, I kicked them out.
Leave!
I'm having an event right now!
Leave, nerds!
Paying customers only!
Not ranked 100%.
Alright.
Nice.
That's right.
You gotta pay a fee if you wanna use my table.
Wow, there's so many holo cards in circulation.
Computer, search Tetramon inflation.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's right.
Loser has to pay- buy 10 packs of cards.
Winner can only buy- only buy 5.
So I think that's pretty good.
And every card pack- is guaranteed holo, so you'll get your money back.
Don't worry, you'll definitely get your money back.
Wait, check my phone.
What's wrong with my phone?
Oh, wait.
There's inflation?
There's fucking inflation?
No.
I'm supposed to leave reality.
What the- I will be scammed.
I will be scammed.
A basic card pack sure is expensive.
Of course they are!
You'll get your money's worth back!
I swear to God, you'll get your money worth.
Can you get a card pack, pay bills?
What do I have to check?
The simulation is getting too real.
Alright, nice.
Buy more tables?
I don't want- Really?
I gotta let more of them- am I?
Am I a store?
But like, I'm here to sell.
Not for loiter.
I don't want to be a loiter.
Alright.
Where do I put it here?
I'll put it here.
Oh, so people will know it's a friendly environment.
Oh my God!
He bought so many!
I'm rich!
We don't need lights.
I don't think I have lights.
No, we don't need the lights.
We need a safe.
We need to save the environment, guys.
We need to save the environment.
Okay, if I put the table in front of the store, they'll think that like, I have- They'll think it'll be a really nice, like, environment, you know?
A nice atmospheric world.
Alright, let me buy more cards.
Oh, I can buy 64 now!
Nice!
Oh.
Oh, it's a license.
I have to have a license to sell more cards?
Oh my God, this is where my taxes go to.
Alright, we'll put all of this here.
Nice.
Is that all of them?
Yeah.
I'm through.
Okay, you played the card game, now you have to stay here.
Alright, might as well open some cards too.
Alright.
Zoom!
Okay.
Come on.
Guys, you see that?
That's a guaranteed holo right there.
This one right here.
Guys.
Guys, that's- Guys, the holo is right there.
Did you guys see it?
Did you- Did you guys see it?
Look!
It's the new box!
Alright?
Oh!
Oh, wait!
There's a holo right there!
There's a holo!
See?
They put all the holos here!
Oh!
Look at that!
Guaranteed holo!
Oh!
Two holos!
I told you!
We don't have a holo on that one, but we have holos in two packs, guys!
We had a holo in two packs!
Oh!
Look at that!
Fucking easy!
And another?
Oh!
Wow!
So- Oh!
And a no-
And it's a first edition!
Oh my god!
You guys all judged me!
Alright.
Let's see.
Where's my...
Where's my fucking...
Do I need to pay biz?
No, I don't.
Thank god.
Okay.
Where's my...
How do I look at my...
Oh, here we go.
Look at that.
Force...
Look at this.
You wish you had your hands on the guppy right now.
Look at this card.
You can see the rainbow.
An EX common.
And a first edition common!
Look at that!
Oh my god, you should have bought your cards at my store.
That's on you.
And look at this!
A basic common foil!
Oh my god!
And I have two of these!
Look at that.
And I'm gonna sell all of them.
Yeah, that's right!
I'm not even gonna collect these.
I'm gonna sell the...
Oh, this is the worst part.
I am a for-profit card shop owner!
It's not even for passion!
I opened this store for profit!
And look at my lo-
You monster!
It's not even for passion!
No way!
Okay.
Oh shit.
I lost money.
Oh, it's because I kept buying stuff.
I didn't lose money.
I just kept buying upgrades.
I'm a scalper.
That's right.
I'm gonna go up there and bring my scal- Oh, oh.
Wait, wait.
I'm sorry.
I'm actually open.
No, come back!
I'm actually...
Come back!
I'm actually open!
I...
No, please come back!
Alright,
I...
I'm open.
Guys, I'm open for real now!
I'm open for real.
Guys, come back!
Guys, please!
I love card games!
Guys, I love card games so much!
I'm passionate!
I'm...
I'm so...
I'm so passionate!
Please!
Okay,
anyway, I can tell the story about...
So, not story, but like...
Another reason why people don't buy from stores anymore...
They try to buy from the official place.
It's that it's really hard to find trustworthy places to buy card packs.
Because you can weigh card packs to find rare cards.
So, like, certain card packs are...
Like, heavier card packs are considered, like, the good ones.
Because the holos tend to be heavier.
Yeah.
So, like, people would just grab the...
They would just grab the holo packs.
And then, like, holo cards out of the packs.
And then put, like, commons in it.
And then reseal it to sell.
Yeah, and that's mostly for Pokemon cards.
I don't know if, like, Yu-Gi-Oh cards have that too.
But I know that...
Like, um...
I know, like, Pokemon cards had that issue.
Anyway, I...
My store doesn't do that, guys.
My store...
Just so you know...
My store does not do that.
Because everybody gets guaranteed holos.
It's real.
It's so real.
Alright.
Small metal rack plate.
Do I need more tables?
I mean, I might as well.
I'll grab another table.
I wanna make my store seem like it's alive.
Okay, let's see.
Oh, wait.
I don't have, like, space anymore.
I say as I have this...
Guys, you don't understand.
This is my box corner.
You don't understand.
This is the corner for my boxes.
Like, it's...
It's very important.
We'll put it in this corner right here.
Can he even sit there?
I think he can.
Oh, wait.
I have a line.
I didn't know that's possible.
Okay, nice.
This guy bought a lot.
You can tell he's passionate.
Oh.
Oh, no.
No.
How do I...
I don't wanna give him $20.
I was like, how do I...
How do I give him...
Okay.
Unlock.
Shop.
Upgrade.
I don't get...
Oh, shit.
I get a cleanser?
What is this for?
Oh, my God.
I can buy figures.
Am I just selling, like, one thing?
Oh, there you go.
Shop expansion.
How do I...
What's the...
Level three.
What is considered level three?
Oh, I don't have it.
Okay.
Let's get...
No.
We don't need a bigger store.
Anyway.
This is insane.
Look.
It's like...
Yo, yo.
You wanna see again?
Watch this.
Oh, my God.
Already.
So easy.
Oh, my God.
I feel so...
Look at that.
Another one.
I told you guys.
Every pack I open is magic.
I hate to...
What?
This guy heard...
This guy heard about my magic store.
My magic store.
He wants in on it.
He was watching the stream and it instantly ran over.
He wanted in on it.
He ran, he ran to my store.
I, guys, by the way, I live stream, you know, those chat, YouTube channels and, like, TikToks that, like, advertise their store by, like, doing, like, day-to-day life of, like, ex, like, what they do, like, at, like, their restaurant store, etc.
This is the day-to-day life of a Tetramon store owner.
And he, I was live streaming my card openings and he let, he fucking ran.
Oh, my gosh!
This girl is watching my stream, too!
They're watching my Tetramon stream!
My Tetramon pack opening!
She also heard about it!
They all heard about the Tetramon card openings.
Card table.
Oh, my God, it's time.
My for-profit store.
The magic touch, the non-rig store.
Okay.
One dollar.
There we go.
Alright, here we go.
Open.
Okay, can I put this here?
Where do I put this?
Oh, I'll put it...
Put it here.
Oh, it has to be, like...
Oh, I'll put it here.
There we go.
And then, I'll put my cards in.
Alright, how is, what's the market value?
Twenty-two dollars.
That's right.
I touched it, so it's worth more.
They'll buy it eventually.
Somebody will buy it.
It has my magic touch, guys.
Alright, let's see.
Sixteen.
There we go.
They'll buy it.
I know they will.
I know, these guys don't know about the internet.
That's why they walked all the way down here.
Oh, I put on my glasses.
I put on my glasses to sell the fact that I know what I'm doing.
Okay, uh...
Oh, it's nine.
Okay, let's see.
Five dollars?
That's right, buy my cards!
Buy my cards!
Alright, let's see.
Alright, let's put that here too.
Uh...
Eight dollars.
Nice.
Oh, he's gonna buy it.
Wait, wait, wait.
He will buy it, guys.
If you don't understand, he will eventually buy it.
You know?
You sound less evil.
What do you mean?
Alright, let's see.
Eight dollars.
But I touched it!
I touched it though!
Don't keep really looking, placing cards like Mr. Higsby from Mega Man Battle.
No way!
Thank you for the super chat, Johnny!
Thank you, thank you!
Guys, come on!
I touched it!
It was on my livestream!
These cards were on my livestream!
They're literally on my livestream!
I'm telling you, it's a famous card!
It's...
Alright, let's see.
I'm going... watch this.
We'll do two pack openings.
Oh!
What can I say?
Every pack!
Just... every pack!
Every...
Every single pack!
It's just that easy!
Every single pack is magic!
Every...
Every single one of them!
It's not a scam!
My...
My Tetramon...
Tetramon store owner, um, underscore 100% is not rigged!
Champion Mel!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
This is my last money.
Can I have the worm?
I wanna be a worm!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
It's not a scam!
Every pack I open is just magic!
It's not rigged 100%!
This used to be the nicest neighborhood!
Wait, the table's not making money?
Stop loitering!
Okay...
Um...
Fees are collected after players?
Alright.
There we go.
Now it's $10.
Fee is too high here?!
Can't decide if I really want this.
There's no way.
It's not even that expensive!
It's literally...
Oh, right there.
Holy shit.
You complain about my fees but then you buy these many cards.
Like, pick a struggle.
I know you're addicted.
You can complain all you want.
But you know you can't leave.
You know you can't stop yourself.
Fine!
Fine, we'll go back to...
We'll go back to this.
Okay.
Changing prices is a niche issue.
Mom, why won't anybody buy these cards?
I literally touched them.
I don't understand.
Maybe if I move it closer to them so they have to see it then people will buy it.
There we go.
They have to look at it now.
No, we gotta save the environment!
We have to save the environment, guys!
Guys, we have to.
Alright.
Since nobody's coming in right now, I can...
It's time.
Wait.
Why can't I...
Why won't it let me...
Guys, it's not letting me pick up a card.
You don't need to see!
Why can't it... Why won't it let me open my card?
No!
Oh, it's right-click.
Sorry.
I was left-clicking.
That
easy.
It's 0.95, but it's still a card valued.
It still has value.
This card still has value, guys.
It's still considered a holo.
It's...
Wait.
What's going on?
What happened to my magic touch?
What happened?
What's going on?
No!
What's going...
What happened?
Where are they?
What happened to my magic touch, guys?
It's because it's...
Okay.
It's because it's nighttime.
It's because it's... Leave.
Leave my sword right now.
You're ruining my magic.
I need you to leave.
I need...
My magic only works in day.
Alright.
That's fine.
You guys will...
He's looking at it.
Oh, dear.
I need to think.
Oh, just think for... Oh.
You're still gonna pay, though.
I knew it.
You're addicted.
You can't...
You can't stop yourself.
I'm not sca...
Oh, this poor guy.
Nobody likes you or wants to play with you.
You poor... Now, leave my store, please.
It's just three.
Just only three people are not happy.
No friends.
Alright.
I told you.
My magic only works in daytime.
The moment... The moment it starts getting dark, I told you.
It's just because it was nighttime.
My magic... My magic touch stops after like...
After 7 p.m.
No way.
I told you.
It's solar powered.
Exactly.
It's solar powered right there.
See, look at that.
6.18.
Look at that.
And she rises again.
When the sun isn't out.
I lose the magic touch.
Oh, hey.
We'll grab this.
And then we'll grab a regular.
Alright.
Open the store?
Look, I was busy trying to...
I was busy doing my...
I was busy opening card packs that...
How many did she fucking... She just took the entire...
This guy just took everything.
He heard it was daytime, so he had to come in.
He...
He heard it was daytime, so he came in and took all the stock.
He's like, I heard the magic starts in day.
I gotta take everything now.
How much did he fucking buy?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, he's going to...
Oh, he's going... Oh, sorry, bro.
She was already there.
Breaking news.
It's...
Daytime.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, it's the boxes!
Okay.
My box corner.
Alright, let's see.
Thirty dollars.
Twenty... Oh, nice!
That should sell.
It'll sell eventually.
It'll sell eventually, guys.
Okay, maybe... Okay, I'll drop the price down by a little bit.
I should really fix the toggle.
Alright, give me a sec.
I'm gonna fix...
I'm gonna disappear for a little bit.
Every time I do prices.
Alright.
Alright, we're fine now.
Okay, we should be good.
Alright, guys.
Okay, I'm gonna just...
I'm gonna adjust the prices just a little bit.
Alright?
I'm not greedy, but I know my worth.
These guys haven't heard of eBay yet.
They haven't heard of eBay yet, so we have hope.
Because, like, why would they...
They haven't heard of eBay or, like, buying from the official places.
So, like, why are they here?
Okay, let's see.
Oh, no.
$7.
It'll get bought eventually, I believe.
Alright.
$21.
I know you'll buy this.
I know you're gonna buy one.
Come on.
It's... See, I told you!
I told you!
Oh!
There we go!
I knew it.
I knew eventually one of you will fold.
I...
Oh!
He bought all three of my boxes!
That's right!
And another one?
This one was the most scammy of them all!
I knew it.
That's true.
eBay is much worse.
eBay, you can't even, like, control it as well.
Okay.
Oh, alright.
$33.
There we go.
We'll have two.
I'm not scamming!
Alright, enough.
Alright, let's buy more boxes.
Oh, hey!
I got... Oh, that 8-pack!
I have enough for that, right?
No, I should just buy one of this.
Alright.
Nice.
I still haven't sold 10 cards yet to a customer, but that's okay.
That doesn't matter.
I'm here for profit.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
Eventually, they'll buy all of this.
When can I, like, have somebody?
Uh...
No, not this.
Wait, what?
Can I change the standard?
Oh, I can't change all of that yet.
Okay, uh, recruit.
Um, Zachary Cole.
I worked in a shop for a few months and gained...
These guys don't, like, look like they're teenagers.
My cards!
Nice.
You saw it on my YouTube channel.
Guys, my YouTube channel's popping off!
My...
Guys, I can't believe it!
My YouTube channel's popping off, guys!
What?
It's a part of the experience.
You hire teenagers so you can pay them less.
And then be like, hey, like, I might pay you less, but I can let you open some of the card packs at my store.
Let's see.
We'll buy...
Oh, it's a quest bud?
Oh well.
Okay, yeah.
Holy shit!
Number one.
Tetramon shop owner underscore 100 fan.
Right here.
This guy just likes my store.
Oh my god, and he's paid $150?
Holy shit.
Addiction personified.
Yeah, I give them store credits so I don't have to pay them.
That's the best part.
Guys, I'm an ethical store owner.
I...
Okay, solar power time.
Alright, what did I get?
Look at that.
I told you!
It only works when the sun is up!
It's just that easy.
The moment the sun rises, it's over.
Ringed and scammed.
It's not rigged!
I'm just... My store is just very... Look at that.
...
Embrace the sun!
Exactly!
Alright.
Nice.
...
It's not my fault you guys don't have the power of the sun by your side.
The magic touch.
Not legally proven to be rigged.
Exactly!
If it was rigged, why would the government let me name my store this?
Why was my business approved?
Alright.
Four dollars.
There you go.
Jeez, wait!
Do you see a scale here?
If I was weighing my... Okay, have you ever seen those like YouTube channels?
Or like YouTube shorts?
Where like, they...
They clear... They're like...
I'm gonna let... I'm gonna let a card shop owner pick a pack for me and then I'm gonna open it at home.
And then it's clear that they like swap the packs to like a rare pack and be like, Oh my god!
The store owner picked this pack and I got a first edition Charizard!
Oh my god!
God!
Anyway, I'm not doing that of course.
That's not my YouTube channel.
Like, we're here for the authentic ca... the authentic experience here.
We're here for the authentic experience.
Alright, let's see.
We'll buy this.
Check out.
I have the money now for this.
Alright.
Ooh!
Look at all these packs!
Wait, where did... Did I not buy this?
Oh, I didn't check out.
Okay, I was like, what the fuck?
I thought it was instant.
Alright.
Nice, the eight pack.
Okay.
Into the corner you go.
Thanks for buying my shop.
Easy.
I got a first edition Charizard.
Meanwhile, the pack was Yu-Gi-Oh!
Alright, let's see.
Small card display.
The auto scent.
The fuck is an auto scent?
Card table, single side, small personal shelf.
Oh, I should... The metal rack!
The actual real TCG experience.
I haven't been to like a...
I haven't been to like a comic book store in a long ass time though.
Um, I don't have anything to put it there.
I just... I just wanted the the rack exactly.
The infamous card rack.
Wait, let me put... Actually, I'm gonna move this next to the counter.
Now!
When you're waiting in line.
You know when you're waiting in line and you see like the rack?
And then you're like, oh wait let me look at the rack before like see if I actually want anything.
The true TCG experience.
Yeah, so like when you queue up, you can't help but like look at this rack.
The temptation rack.
The impulsive fires.
It needs to be against the wall.
That's true.
Right here.
Oh, there it is.
The first thing they see.
Hey guys, you guys wanna...
Oh wait, $46.
That's fine.
I got the money already.
I need to spend money exactly.
Wait, do I have enough?
Do I have enough to buy an extra?
Oh no, I don't.
What about accessories?
Do I need this?
What is this assess...
What is it for?
Oh wait, I have card sleeves.
Wait, I should buy some card sleeves.
Guys, can you guys please spend some money?
I need...
I need... I need... Okay, let's open some more packs, guys.
Oh no, the sun is coming down.
The sun is coming down.
No!
The sun is coming down!
The sun was...
No!
I just realized it.
What bills?
Oh, that bill.
Whoops.
Okay.
Oh, look at that!
Look at how low my electricity bill was!
I like how my electricity bill was so low because I don't turn on the lights.
Guys, please.
I need... Oh, I forgot to set the price for this.
Five.
The electric bill is crazy, I heard.
Just to thank you for the super chat.
Now if you don't, you turn on the lights.
I'm here to save the environment here.
I'm the reverse vampire.
Guys, I need you guys to hurry up.
Guys, if you're not gonna pay, I need you to hurry up, guys.
Please.
Oh, look at all his rare cards.
Oh, you can't see because the lights are off.
Buddy.
We're one hour till closing time.
Nobody is here to play.
with you.
Like...
UNLESS!
Never mind.
I forgot you have friends.
Sorry, I got you mixed up with that other guy in the corner that had nobody else playing with him.
Unless he called a friend.
Sorry, I got him confused with that other guy.
You know that other guy that sat in the corner for two hours?
I thought that was him.
I just... I can't have him loitering.
I just can't have these guys loitering.
Chat.
Like, I'm here to run a business.
I'm here to run a business.
I feel personally attacked.
Oh, nice.
He bought two boosters.
Oh, that's sixty dollars.
Sixty smackaroonies right here.
Oh, and they're gonna play card games.
Okay, we're gonna wait until these guys finish.
Because I need to get paid.
I need...
I need to get paid.
I need these guys.
And he's looking at the cards.
Oh, I can get them to pay in advance?
No, I can't.
That moves the cards.
Oh, he bought one of the rare cards!
Nice.
Okay, and I can put another one in here.
How much is that?
Okay, I can put six dollars.
I can upsold it.
Alright, guys.
I need you guys to hurry up.
Guys, I need you guys.
Why would I close the store if I can get money?
Oh, wait.
My store's not closed!
Come in here!
No, come back!
I can see the wallet!
Guys, I can see!
I know you want cards!
Guys, please.
Please.
Come on.
Card game cannot be that long.
Don't step on their cards.
Gonna lose value.
If I lose...
That means they need replacements.
If I step on their cards, they're gonna wanna replace those cards for these brand new cards right here.
Created 10 PSA 10 right here.
All these cards that are not in any sleeves or containers are PSA 10.
Alright.
This is here.
By the way, I own a PSA grading company too.
I also own the PSA company that grades these cards.
Alright.
Where the hell are the lights?
I am a small business owner.
Please don't criticize...
I'm just a small business owner.
Guys.
Please.
I'm just trying to make it in this world.
Sorry.
I'm not big like Toys R Us.
I'm just trying to make it.
Alright.
We'll buy the regular packs here.
So we can check out.
Nice.
Okay.
I have five more days.
I will put these booster packs here to tempt them.
You know you want to buy the cards on the rack.
You know you want to.
Just a horribly small predatory business.
It's not predatory!
I don't know where you guys get that idea.
Alright.
Here we go.
The magic touch.
The sun is out.
Look at that.
Oh!
And another one too.
Look at that.
It's just that easy.
The sun is out.
My power continues.
Oh!
Another one?
Look at that.
I skipped it, but you saw it.
I skipped it, but you guys saw it.
Praise the sun.
I know you all saw it.
It even works on the racks too.
Watch.
Oh!
Wait!
Oh my God!
Look at that!
Six, six, six!
The gold!
I always think the holo cards are at the end because you know how like in Pokemon cards, if you put two cards in the... if you take two cards from the back and put it in the front, um...
So you can have like... you can skip the... what was it?
You'll know like the...
You'll know like the holo is at the end.
So I keep thinking that the card is always at the end because I used to watch MaxMofo do like card opening streams.
Or not streams, card opening videos.
And he's always like, let's take two cards from the back and put it in the front and that's like stuck in my head.
I always think that's how it goes.
Alright.
Oh, look at all these rare cards that I'm gonna sell because I'm a for prop.
This is not a passion, it's...
This is a for profit store.
What a great collection that I can sell.
The soulless card shop owner.
Oh nice, he bought that card at episode two.
Alright, here we go.
For profit but still owes rent.
Alright, nice.
Let's see.
Nine dollars.
Let's go.
I got achievement!
What did I get?
Thirty-four.
Okay.
Let's see.
I need to... I need to...
Oh yeah, I should pay rent now.
There we go.
I'm gonna get another uh...
AutoSend.
Does this even matter?
Small warehouse.
Oh yeah, I need to save up for another table.
Let's see.
Yeah, I need to save up.
So the ones in my town.
Yeah.
Just your locals.
Guys, we're gonna reach a hundred K subscribers!
I'm a not rigged shop owner!
Wait, no.
Sorry, I have multiple channels.
Cause like, I have multiple channels to try and make it big.
You know?
And I'm...
So I'm trying to remember which channel was it that's close to a hundred K.
Trying to hit the algorithm.
The grind never stops.
Not rigged TCG shop.
Expand the shop.
Oh, that's why I needed the cent.
Oh, it's okay.
It's okay.
At least he has the money though.
Now I understand what the cent was for.
Alright, thirty-four.
Okay, we're almost to four hundred dollars.
He's not here to play the card game, so we're fine.
We're fine.
Uh-oh, stinky.
We should have... Now I know why we have the cleanser.
Okay, let's see.
Uh, accessories.
Cleanser.
Purchase to unlock.
What is this for?
Is this actually for like...
Is this to clean the cards or clean themselves?
I can't tell.
I'll just put it here.
The game or a... I can't tell.
Is it...
Is it to clean the cards or clean the people?
I don't know.
I can't tell which is which.
Like...
Oh, can I actually take the item?
Oh, I can!
Just in case.
Oh, I actually... Okay, but what if people buy it, though?
What if people buy it?
You don't know that.
Maybe they'll actually buy it.
Oh, I need more cards.
Um...
Do you wear in the card shop?
Anyway, guys.
I'm having a special promotion right now.
Um, I made a short...
A YouTube short.
It's TCG Shop Owner Underscore 100%.
Um, and to celebrate 100k subscribers, one lucky person Um...
One lucky person will get a free pack for only 10.99.
But just one.
Also, the sun is out, so we all know what that means.
Hashtag add.
Wait a minute.
The sun is out.
No.
What's going on?
The sun is out.
Wait.
What's going on?
The sun is out, though!
The sun...
Is the sun setting?
Maybe I...
Maybe I have to go out.
Maybe I need to absorb the sun a little bit longer.
Maybe... What's happening?
What's happening?
Oh!
It's alright.
No, no, no, no.
Because I have the rack, my luck, my power transferred over only to the...
only to the rack cards.
So, that's what's happened.
That's...
OH MY GOD!
I GOT A GOLD EDITION ANGEL FISH!
We're so back.
I told you.
We're so...
Oh, hey, look.
They bought... Look.
See?
She bought the spray.
She bought the spray to play...
Oh, that's fucked.
That's...
She bought the spray and took it to her table.
She knows.
She knows what's up.
The spray.
Guys, I told you.
It's because...
It's because my power transferred over to the...
Look at that.
The disrespect.
This isn't her first rodeo.
She was like, I don't know how to play this guy.
I'll take two of your... I like how she bought two of the spray cans too.
Not just one, but two of them.
She's in it for the long haul.
Actually, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
How much is that secret rare Doki Bird card in the window?
I bought the entire stock.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um, Austin, thank you for your third super chat.
Abusing customers is wild.
Guys, they read the fine print.
They came back.
They could have left.
You know, you know this is what they wanted.
I'm not the only TCG shop owner in this town.
Like, maybe I am.
Maybe the other stores went bankrupt during COVID.
But, but...
Wait, maybe I am, guys.
I think I am.
I think the other I think the other stores went bankrupt after COVID.
So, I am all they have left.
I am the only crazy person that's willing to open a TCG store while there's online shops of cards where they can just buy from GameStop.
Let's see.
$12.
Nice.
It's a monopoly.
Yay!
...
Abusing a monopoly.
I'm the only one crazy enough to open a Tetra...
a Tetramon exclusive shop too.
I don't sell any other card games.
If you're gonna come here to buy Yu-Gi-Oh cards or Pokemon cards or Magic the Gathering cards, fucking leave my store.
You can only play Tetramon only.
I have an exclusive contract with Tetramon.
In this entire country of Canada, this is the only place you can buy Tetramon cards.
You have...
I don't care if you live in Winnipeg or something.
You gotta travel all the way down...
Oh god.
I see...
Okay.
Sorry.
Anyway, back to my monologue.
In the entire country of Canada, you have to travel down here!
In an undisclosed location!
Because I don't want to dox myself.
Just for Tetramon cards!
Oh, he came in there with his friend.
He knows what's up.
That's wild.
Somewhere in the west coast, this is where the only place you can buy Tetramon cards.
Alright.
I think I need more deodorant.
I think.
Bankrupt equals doki showed up overnight with a bat.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, we actually...
We need more... Oh shit!
Rare card pack!
Wait, I want that.
Do I buy... Okay, but deodorant...
Oh...
Deodorant was making so much money though.
Okay, let's...
Okay, we need $300.
That's fine.
Why is it taking so long to make money?
Guys, where did you hear about this light situation?
There's no lights here.
I don't know.
I have no idea where you get the idea that we have lights, guys.
I purposely made sure this store was environmentally friendly.
So I took out all the lights.
Alright, let's see.
No, I can't.
I cannot.
The sun's not out.
Resist the temptation, doki.
Resist the temptation.
Your friend's not coming.
It's time to leave.
Sir.
Wait, isn't that the guy sprayed?
No, that's not him.
Alright, guys.
Come on, guys.
Can't keep playing card games in here.
The store is closed, guys.
No loitering, guys.
No loitering.
Guys!
Come on!
If you're not gonna pay, you gotta leave.
Don't do that.
Spray them away.
Guys, no loitering!
Guys!
Go!
Wait!
Leave!
It's okay.
I can still sell this.
It's fine.
Wait, I can?
Oh, I can.
Thank God.
Alright.
If you're gonna be here, I'm still gonna close the store.
Nice!
I made profit!
Let's go!
Alright.
You just need one...
Oh, hey!
Okay, we just need to sell this card.
Uh...
Seven dollars...
Six dollars?
Yeah.
That's fine.
Oh, come in, come in, guys!
We're open!
Alright.
We're open now, for real.
Now we're actually open.
Alright.
Use the Axe Spray to spray them away.
Hey there, girl.
Want some cards?
You want some Tetra Monk?
Girl, you want some Tetra Monk?
Yeah, I knew you wanted Tetra Monk.
Oh, wait, there's the trash can.
Oh, you got the rack.
It's working.
The rack is working.
Oh, this is fine?
Nice.
Okay.
Let's put more cards in here.
Okay, nice.
Alright, what did you buy?
Oh, the Golden Nimbus card?
Yeah, I heard that card is fine.
Thirteen dollars.
Let's go.
Alright, maybe I can afford...
Oh, I can afford it!
I can afford the license!
Nice.
Oh, I can afford the rare card packs now!
Okay, when can I afford, like, a kid to work for me?
Level ten?
I'm only level five?
This is gonna take fucking forever!
Okay, nine dollars.
Wait, I think he also bought another card.
Okay, let's see.
Uh, five dollars.
Okay, there we go.
Uh, successfully complete a hundred checkouts.
Oh my god, I've been going in there for a while now.
Alright, let's put the rare cards.
Oh, I forgot about the booster pack shit!
That makes sense.
Chuck that in here.
Okay, how much is market price?
Five dollars now.
Alright, if I need to buy, like, the booster pack shit.
Guys, please, can I spend some money?
Guys?
Oh, wait!
You're right.
It's time.
What is this fucking rare card bullshit?
What is this?
Get back in the box.
You gotta go on the rack.
You gotta
Yeah, go in the rack.
There we go.
This time it'll be different.
Wait.
Okay.
What's going on?
This is a scam.
What the fuck is going on?
Maybe it's cause I didn't open it in the sun.
Maybe that's it.
The punishment rack.
What is going on?
Did my fucking distributor scam me?
Oh my god.
My distributor weighed the packs.
He fucking weighed the packs.
Her streak is over.
Oh my god.
I got I bought this box.
I bought that box from eBay.
I fucked up.
I bought the box from eBay guys and they weighed the pack.
Oh damn.
Okay.
Okay guys.
To be fair, this pack was more lucky though.
No!
Oh!
It's okay.
The ball!
It's cause I didn't get the heart.
It made up for it.
Look at that.
Not punished.
They They resealed the pack.
I got two to make up for the duds.
That's fine.
It made up for it.
It evens out.
It's okay.
Everything evened out in the end.
Wait.
Too much.
Oh thank god.
Thank god it stopped me.
Alright.
What was this?
$7.
There we go.
Yeah.
99% This is why I didn't quit.
I didn't quit opening packs chat.
99% of gamblers quit before they make it big.
Exactly.
And I never stopped.
I knew my luck was gonna change today.
Alright.
We're so back.
Oh shit.
They actually bought my used cans.
First edition.
Silver edition.
Easy.
They didn't get all of them.
They didn't reseal all of them.
Guys I need $400 so I can buy another card.
Dang.
8.50 50 cents.
This is the first time I have to use coins there.
Let's go gambling.
Oh dang it.
Maybe if I stop opening cards.
I can actually make money.
Maybe.
It could be a possibility but I gotta think about it chat.
I have to think about it a bit longer.
That sounds like a gambler quitting.
I'm just I'm thinking about it.
It doesn't mean I'm committing to it.
I'm just thinking about it.
Yeah.
What a thought.
Oh he bought a card as well.
Nice.
Okay I should put more cards in here.
Uh...
$8.
And then...
What's this?
$8.
And then what should I put here?
This guy.
The...
Decimite.
I wish I could actually play these card games.
I think that would be fun too.
Oh he bought the box.
He knows that's where the real money is.
He knows I can't weigh those.
This is how a terrifying pretty cardboard addiction starts.
Lolly thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Can I open a box?
Let's see.
Oh my god I can.
I can just open all of this.
Oh my god you're right.
You're right.
Oh my god I could just literally just keep opening.
I know I could have made more money but...
Oh look at that!
Guys I know I could have just made more money if I just sold the entire box.
But this is different.
You don't understand.
Oh!
I should just keep opening boxes.
I should...
This is where all my money goes into.
This is it.
Oh my god there was a holo!
Guys I get holos so many times that like it's not even special to me anymore.
It's not even that special anymore.
I'm just like oh.
Another one?
Wow.
Cause it's guaranteed every time in my store.
It's always guaranteed in my store so...
Oh look at that!
Look at that!
That's it.
She's beyond saving.
And I literally just made back my money.
Right there.
Literally just made back everything.
Alright.
A hundred and twenty and three.
Oh maybe like actually what's like the ten percent markup for this?
Oh a hundred and thirty?
Let's do it.
We'll put a hundred and thirty here.
And then we'll put this here.
And this here.
We've lost it.
Guys if I keep opening why would I sell these when I can just open them?
Like why?
Guys I'm so stupid.
This is the real money maker.
Why would I Why would I sell the boxes?
When I can make back all my money opening the boxes chat.
Look at that.
Come on.
There has to be another rare.
Please stop.
Toki no you gotta stop.
The sun is coming out Toki.
The sun is setting.
You have to stop.
No.
There has to be.
My magic.
I stored up the magic here.
There has to be another one.
There has to be another rare.
She has stopped pretending to realize.
No.
It has to be the last pack.
It's the last pack.
It has to be.
Oh no.
No.
Is it because of the sun?
Okay.
Another sun.
I got like some stuff.
We lost her.
It's okay.
It's because the sun is going down.
That's the only reason chat.
That's the only reason the sun went down.
So it's okay.
It's okay.
The moment we hit the next morning it'll be okay.
It'll be okay.
What card did you get?
Oh, you got the EX Wurmple.
$11.
Nice.
Donkey Bird Gambling Fun.
Sir, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's okay.
This is the card opening stream.
You know how all these other Vtubers do card opening stream?
I do it too but virtually because I'm more immersive.
I'm here to give you the immersion guys.
I'm here to give you the immersion.
Guys, okay, wait.
$4.
So we'll put that as market price.
Okay.
So I'll put it at $6 then.
Guys, I know the sun is out but guys, all I'm saying is that I know the sun is out but I have stored some magic inside me.
There's no way.
I literally stored the magic.
Wait, wait.
That was a hook.
I stored some magic.
There's a hollow.
There has to be another rare.
Did you see that?
That's a hollow.
Even hollows don't give me that excited.
No.
Even hollows don't even give me excited anymore.
Ever since I got that $100 card, I'm chasing that high.
I need that high again.
I need that $100 high!
She's building a tolerance.
Oh!
But that's not even $100!
Oh my god.
Come on.
There has to be a hundred.
Where is it?
There has to be another one.
I just want to get the $1k card.
She's in too deep now.
You guys don't understand.
You don't understand.
When you get that jackpot, you can't stop.
You just want to get that card again.
You want to know how that feels.
It was just such a good feeling and you want to chase it.
You want to feel that.
You want to feel that energy again.
That excitement again.
You got to chase it until you can feel it again.
Come on.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Maybe try putting them in boxes.
You're right.
Maybe the rack will bring me good luck.
Oh my god.
You're so right.
Maybe I'll just put it down here.
If I put it down here and let it absorb the sun magic.
Maybe.
I'll just let it absorb the sun magic.
Like absorb it all up.
And then maybe it's time.
Get out.
I need the sun to come out.
I need you to leave.
I need you to leave so I can have the sun.
No!
He bought two boxes!
Money!
No!
He knew.
I'm saving up for that!
Okay.
I need to buy another card display.
A card table.
Yeah.
This is what I was saving for.
So I can sell more of my cards.
Okay.
There.
You have to look at it now.
Okay.
I'll put it here.
Put all of them here.
I'll make back my money through the individual cards.
Oh.
I'll make it all back.
I can feel it.
I can feel myself making it all back.
I'll pay my bill soon.
I swear to God.
I'll pay it soon.
I swear.
Okay.
And then this should be $4.
This should be also $4.
Okay.
And then $5.
Uh...
$5.
This one also should be...
Wait.
Did I just...
$5.
Here we go.
And this one will be $5.
There we go.
Alright.
We're open.
Oh, my bills.
It's okay.
I have six days.
I don't have to worry.
It's time.
Hi.
This is it.
That cost $5.
$5.
Fucking leave.
You don't appreciate true value.
This has been on my YouTube channel.
Alright.
That's not...
That's not it.
It's not the same.
The sparkles don't...
Oh, my God.
Oh, it's $11.
It's not the same.
It's just a one second excitement.
One second high.
It doesn't capture that moment.
That's what I did when I opened that $100 card.
It's...
It only lasted one second.
I need that.
I need that $100.
I need that five second high.
I need...
I need at least five seconds to be satisfied.
Come on.
I need to see high numbers.
No!
It's okay.
If they keep spending money, I'll be able to afford another box.
Guys, please.
Please spend money.
I need to afford boxes.
Guys.
Guys, please.
Please.
I need you guys.
I need you guys to spend...
Spend those boxes.
I need to buy boxes.
Please.
Okay, guys.
I'll move.
I'll let you see the money.
Bye.
Are you satisfied?
Now I'm on the left side.
It's so weird to be on the left side.
Chat.
You buy individual packs?
Don't you know the money is where...
Where the boxes are?
Are you doing this for passion?
I can't believe it.
This feels so wrong.
It does.
It feels so wrong.
I feel so out of place being on the side.
Okay.
Let's see boxes.
Eight boxes.
Guys, please.
Leave so I can leave.
$14.
It's almost there.
Where are you looking at?
There's nothing there.
What are you even looking at?
Oh, buy those cards.
Come on, I just need...
I need $14.
Why are you loitering back to the empty box?
No, don't leave.
I need $14.
Making some money isn't enough.
You need to make all the money.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, $6.
We're almost there.
Oh, nice.
He bought a card.
He almost gave him change.
Where's that card coming from?
Right here.
Okay.
That should be $14.
Oh, yeah.
$14.
There we go.
Thank you for your very first super chat.
Thank you.
I just bought three boxes of one piece.
Let's go broke together.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I heard that...
Wait, what boxes has a...
One of the boxes has a box?
Which one is it?
Is it this one?
No.
Oh my god.
Alright, I can't find it.
I can't be bothered.
Oh, it is.
I am a true believer of the Singapore.
Okay.
The boxes was what where my luck was.
Wait.
Did I actually put two?
Okay, we can only afford one.
We're not made of money right now.
This is it.
Nobody can get my boxes.
I'm putting it here.
No one can buy my boxes.
Nobody can buy my boxes.
The boxes is just for me.
It's only for me.
Come on, give me that high again.
I need it.
I need to feel this.
I need three dollars.
Come on.
There has to be a bigger...
We're so good.
Yuki, what about the bills?
These cards will pay for my bills.
The hundred dollar card will pay for my bills.
We've lost her.
We've lost her chat.
She only did this unironically.
But now she's too gone.
She's too far in.
Opening packs in the street.
Like a sane person.
Azurak, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, fine.
I'll do one pack.
I'll do one more pack.
But if this pack doesn't give me that hundred dollar thrill.
I'll give you a hundred dollars.
Pathetic.
Told you.
I told you it's not the same.
It's not the same.
Not my lovely area right here.
Just one more.
Come on.
There has to be that hundred dollar.
Doki- No!
Just one more hit.
Oh my god.
They're just stupid hollows.
It's not the same.
I need, I need, I need five digits in there.
Incoming Doki- Dead.
I just...
I just need to know what it's like again.
I need to know what it's like again.
I need to know.
The hunt for the ultra rank.
Come on.
He can wait.
That guy over there can wait.
Children card for addiction.
Addiction.
0.5 second.
Only 0.5 second of joy.
It's getting worse chat.
It's getting worse.
Please stop.
It's okay.
The next box.
It has to be the next box.
It's getting shorter.
It's the next box.
I can feel it.
The next box will bring me pure joy.
Okay, what did he buy?
Okay, one dollar.
Oh, I can pay my bills now.
Okay, that's good.
But I can also buy a box.
Okay, wait.
Bills.
I have six days.
I can buy another box.
Not enough money?
It's 114.
What do you mean?
I need to pay a delivery fee?
Why do you try to fucking deliver me?
It's just cardboard.
Why do you try to deliver?
It's fucking cardboard.
These delivery men don't need my five dollars of money.
You should have pot prived.
Come on.
It's not the same.
Where is it?
It baited me.
It fucking baited me.
I thought it was true value.
I don't need that card.
It's not.
Ten dollars?
What do you think I am?
A fucking single pack owner?
Okay.
It's okay.
0.0 Come on.
Where is it?
Do I like scroll, sort my album?
Price.
This is my most expensive.
And then, oh I can like look at my pages here.
Oh my god.
I do not have a lot.
.
Did Doki really change when she went to the left side?
I still have so many.
It's okay.
Eventually.
I'll eventually get that pack again.
I'll eventually get it.
Nine dollars?
Talk to me when you add two more zeros at the end.
I want the right side Doki back.
On the right side Doki at least actually let the customers buy the cards.
Doki you're not even selling cards.
It doesn't matter.
Add two more zeros to it.
Have you made the money back?
I don't know what's going on in my store right now.
I'm opening packs.
.
Doki don't do it.
What even is going on in my store?
I'm too busy opening card packs.
I still have cards.
It's fine.
.
Let's see.
Oh wait, I have to do Q.
Okay.
I'm going to go back to the beginning.
.
Twenty one.
There we go.
I have cards everywhere?
That's good, I do.
Okay.
Oh shit, exactly?
Wait, what the fuck did he buy?
Okay, that's fine.
Okay, let's see.
Are they supposed to leave?
No, it's still night time.
Oh yeah!
I have enough!
For more boxes.
Wait, can I have the rare one yet?
Level 12.
No, it's fine.
I'll just buy these.
I'm fine with just buying these.
Oh my god, I can buy two.
I can buy... I can just...
I just haven't...
No, we'll do one for now.
We'll do one for now.
Okay.
That's good.
Nobody touch this.
These are mine.
Nobody touch these.
Nobody.
Guys, it's okay.
Look.
I have six days.
It's due in six days.
It's fine.
What are you gonna do?
Shut me down?
Nobody touch... No, I saw you.
I saw you.
You were looking at these boxes of my cards.
I fucking see you.
This is my card box.
This is mine.
Don't you dare touch it.
Don't you?
This is my... These are my cards.
I'm watching all of you.
I'm fucking watching you guys.
You think I don't know?
You think... No!
No!
This... Oh, no.
Oh, no.
He's here for my fucking cards.
I can feel it.
No.
No, he's here for my cards.
Where is he?
Get away.
Get away from my cards.
Okay.
Let's put that in the corner.
I'm calling for a certain store manager.
All right.
Nice.
I need a bomb of the peasant booster packs.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Whoops.
That's not what I wanted to do.
Oh, I know.
I know.
Now they'll never steal.
No, I can't.
I was going to put it behind the front of this so they'll never be able to...
So I can always keep my eye on it.
All right.
What was that?
Oh, yeah.
I need regular packs.
The regular packs for the commoners.
All right.
These guys, I don't care as much for.
I know it is me.
My cards don't touch.
Guys, I don't need to pay for my lighting bills yet.
I have six more days.
All right.
Leave.
I need to open my cards.
Leave right now.
Omni, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, just got here.
The game seems fun, but are you okay?
You seem a little on edge.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I'm just enjoying my day being a card.
I'm a shop owner.
It's fine.
Doki, please open this door.
No, it's okay.
It's okay.
Cards first.
Exactly.
I'm having the time of my life.
Okay.
Come on.
Give me that.
97.
So close.
It's not the same.
Not even a hundred dollars.
It might as well be fucking dirt on the ground.
I might as well just rip that card.
What do you mean?
It's not a hundred.
It's not.
It might as well be five.
It might as well be five dollars.
Yeah.
Okay.
See.
It's not what I mean.
What Tetra Vaan does to a person.
Okay.
14.
A hundred.
It might as well be a hundred.
Oh wait.
No, I shouldn't.
That should be Market Price 10%.
There we go.
May I interest you in Candler's Anonymous?
I don't have a problem!
She said calmly.
Okay.
That's fine.
I told you these boxes were worth it.
I told you.
Might as well be one cent.
It might as well be a fucking freebie.
I can stop whenever I want, chat.
I can stop whenever I fucking want.
Wait, I can afford more boxes!
Guys!
I can afford more boxes guys!
Oh my god.
I just made enough.
I just made enough to buy another eight pack.
Oh my god!
Get that phone in!
I can afford another eight pack.
Let's fucking go!
Okay.
Get away!
Get away, dude.
This is mine.
Get away.
Don't you dare.
Don't you dare come close to it.
This is my corner of boxes.
These are Don't you fucking dare.
I have five more days to pay rent!
It's fine!
Four more days to pay rent!
I have plenty of time.
Look, see?
Look, five days.
As long as I pay bills by the end of the day, it'll be okay.
It'll be okay.
Do you save up money you can open a box of rare packs?
Yeah, but I need to be level 12!
It doesn't matter!
All I can do is... I need to be level nine!
Look, for the people, because I feel very generous right now, look, I will give one.
There you go.
See?
I am so generous.
I am willing to sell one of my boxes that I bought with my money.
What if the hundred is in that one?
You're so right!
No, no, you're so right.
You're so fucking right.
I should... oh my god, how could I?
Oh my god, why would I?
Oh my god, I can't believe I almost went crazy there.
Thank you, thank you, man.
Thank you for telling me, making me, breaking me up, with that crazy spell I had, because I was so close.
I can't believe I almost went crazy there, for a second.
Thank you for giving me rational thought right there.
You're so right.
This could be the winning box chat.
This could actually be...
I... I'm...
I'm taking it straight now.
Alright.
Nine dollars.
Use your nine.
Okay, and then one dollar.
Wait, I can't buy more.
Guys.
Oh my god.
I can buy another box.
I just made enough.
For my corner.
Oh my god, I literally just made enough.
Alright.
Another box.
Gotta make sure nobody takes this.
Alright.
Come on.
Guys, I have five more days to pay my bills.
As long as I pay my bills, at the end of the day, it will work.
Fucking trash.
They run the store, so you can level up.
Sorry, Donkey, but this has to stop.
I can stop whenever I want.
Gladstone.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I can stop whenever I want.
I don't have a problem.
I'm just trying to...
Oh, fucking trash.
It might as well be...
It might as well be garbage.
Come on.
Give me that hundred dollars.
I need it to hit a hundred dollars.
Okay.
Rare packs.
Oh, she bought cards.
Oh, 16?
Oh shit, that gave you too much money.
Uh, 16.
Okay.
She bought cards.
Uh, which card did you buy?
Oh, you bought this one.
Alright, that is market price 62.
Alright, there we go.
That's fine.
Want me to restock anything?
No, that's okay.
I can keep going.
Come on.
Eventually, I'll hit that hundred dollars.
If I spend 300...
500 dollars in boxes, eventually that one box will be a hundred banger.
That's how probability works, guys.
That's...
That's how it works.
500 dollars will eventually get me that hundred dollar profit.
It's right there.
I can feel it.
Let's go!
I knew it!
Yes!
I fucking knew it!
You all doubted me!
You all fucking...
None of you were believers!
Never quit!
Oh my god!
I fucking knew it!
It was the last pack, too!
Oh my god!
Get this fucking card out of here!
Get this card out of here!
I need my... Where is it?
I need to put that fucking price...
Where is it?
Where the fuck is my 400 dollar card?
Where the fuck is it?
Where is my 400 dollar card?
Where the fuck is my 400...
Where is...
Oh there it is!
Look at that!
Four hundred and five dollars!
Now time to sell this fucking...
Five boxes right there!
Guys, you don't understand!
That's five boxes!
That's five eight packs right there!
That's gonna get me five eight packs right there!
I'm gonna have so much money right there!
Pay here!
Oh god!
No!
I don't want the card!
Okay.
That's right, get clean!
Get clean!
Okay, I'm gonna resell this.
People will buy it.
They don't know.
Alright.
We can do this again.
Oh my god!
I knew if you don't...
I knew it!
None of you believed me!
None of you fucking believed me!
I told you!
If I hoard all the boxes!
If I hoard all the boxes, I'll eventually get the good cards!
If I keep hoarding it...
I knew the boxes had the good shit!
I fucking knew it!
I'm gonna sell it for 500!
You think I'll actually pay for 500?
You're right!
If I sell it for 500, I can get 5 boxes of cards!
You're so right!
You're...
Chat!
Oh my god!
How could I be so delusional?
Selling for 445!
He's just... He's not even here for cards.
He's just here for deodorant.
Oh my god!
Wait!
I can buy...
I can buy... I can buy two more boxes right now!
I can literally... I can literally buy two boxes right now!
You're so...
Oh wait!
You're right!
$499.99!
They'll think it's a bargain!
Oh my god!
Since I put it at $500, and then I put it down at $499.99, then that means they'll be like, oh my god!
It's like 10% off!
They'll think it's 10% off at that point.
Wait for $1.99.
Who fucking cares?
That's not $400.
It doesn't matter.
Look!
The bill man's not gonna... The IRS...
The bank is not gonna repossess my store until like...
If I... If I pay at the last day, they're not gonna repossess my store, guys.
They're not...
As long as the store gets paid and as long as the bills... Look, see?
I have five more days.
I have five more days of this.
I can keep going.
I don't have a problem.
Oh my god, I almost forgot the most important thing.
I almost forgot.
I can't believe I could be so foolish.
I'm gonna buy two boxes now.
Oh my god.
I was so foolish.
I was so foolish into thinking.
Oh my god, I can literally...
I can literally pay for this now.
This is fine.
Look, I just... Look.
I just need to pay.
Like, it's only 150.
I can do that later.
I can pay 150 later.
I...
I'm investing, guys.
You don't understand.
This is an investment.
Exactly.
Any card that's less than 250 dollars is a waste of my time.
And my money.
And it is an insult to my customers.
As in me.
I am the customer.
I...
And it is an insult to me.
Yes, they are.
Yes, they are buying a single card.
You don't understand.
Maybe...
Okay, but what if... Okay, wait.
Alright.
I'll do 445.99.
That'll be such a steal.
That'll be... Look at these single pack losers.
Yeah.
Buying single packs.
They don't know the ultimate hack.
Buy the boxes.
That's where all the money is.
That's...
They don't need lights.
They'll play in whatever environment I tell them to play.
Leave.
Leave the store.
Nobody's gonna play with you.
And I need to close the store in like...
in like 10 minutes.
Nobody's gonna be playing.
Leave.
I need the light to open my... Oh my god.
140.42.
You know what that means.
It's another set of boxes.
Right here.
Oh my god.
More cards.
Right here.
My little...
Oh.
Holy...
Shit.
That's... She's feeding my addiction.
She... No.
It's not addiction.
It's a lifestyle.
She's feeding into my perfectly normal hobby.
Guys.
She knows.
She...
She cares.
She truly cares about me.
Okay.
Alright.
Nobody get close to it.
This is my corner.
Nope.
Don't you fucking dare.
Get close to my box.
I'm gonna put it right here for now.
I'm gonna put it right here so I can open it and then open.
Nobody touch my box.
Nobody touch it.
Alright.
There we go.
We gotta keep going.
We're gonna get that ultimate rare card.
This is it.
It can't be...
It has to be more than $200.
Shit.
That's nothing to me.
That's nothing.
$74?
Might be like fucking regular paper then.
Get out.
No litter.
Buy real card bags.
Never stop.
If you stop gambling right now, you're gonna...
You're gonna miss out on hitting it big.
Okay.
$8.
I still have...
I'm like... I'm like so close to being able to afford to pay... to buy more packs.
To buy more boxes.
Might as well be toilet paper.
Exactly.
You give me... That's just extra toilet paper.
I don't need to buy toilet paper when I have garbage cards like these.
Fucking $11?
99% gamblers quit before they hit it big.
Exactly.
You know what's up.
Okay.
$14.
Since the Tetramon addiction is real, I might as well ask a thousand Pokemon pack opening.
Alright.
When the fuck is Pokemon?
I am only loyal to my one and only Tetramon.
Pokemon wishes they can be as good as Tetramon.
Alright.
Let's put those cards in here.
Whoops.
What?
Okay.
How do I... Oh, sort my album.
Do I have any destiny cards?
No.
I only have Tetramon.
Alright.
Uh...
Market price.
There we go.
Oh, I have another one that's sold.
Market price 10%.
There we go.
Uh...
$14.
Oh my god.
This is like taking time away from what I actually care about.
Hahahaha.
Fucking... I need a higher...
I need to be level 10 so I can just full time commit to this.
Like...
No, they're fine.
The shells are fine.
It has everything they need.
I have stuff on the rack.
Doesn't matter.
I have the stuff on the rack.
That's all they need.
Hahahaha.
Alright.
Come on.
There has to be another $200 card somewhere in here.
There has to be... Oh my god!
I just made enough!
Who cares about that?
It's not even $100.
Come on.
We'll hit it big.
Oh, that's good.
That's good.
They continue to feed my addiction.
Where's my box?
There it is.
Hahahaha.
I mean, not my addiction.
There it is.
My perfectly normal hobby.
That I don't have a problem with.
Uh...
106.47.
Alright, here we go.
Okay.
That here.
Market price.
There we go.
It's fine.
I'm...
I was wondering how people fall into addiction.
But now, thanks to Doki, I now understand.
Come on.
There has to be another one.
There has to be $40.
Get out of my fucking eyes!
I might as well I might as well feed this car to my fucking dog.
I might as well fucking put it on the sidewalk and let the cars run over it.
One for the shelf, one for you.
One for the shelf?!
That's way too many ones.
What do you mean?
Okay.
Here we go.
Wait, can I buy other stuff now?
What is it?
Oh, I can buy card sleeves.
Okay, fine.
I'll buy... Oh wait, what's this?
Dice.
Oh, there's other stuff?
I guess I'll let you guys have some dice.
Oh, $200?
That's way too many dice.
Oh, there's figures!
Oh, wait, that's cute!
Wait, that's pretty cute.
What other stuff?
Wait, I can't afford my stuff anymore.
Okay, we still have booster packs here.
And then...
Okay, trash.
Trash area.
Now to do what I'm truly passionate about.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying!
Yay!
$200 for dice?
I better make some actual money off of those.
That's fine, we don't need those.
Okay, nope.
Come on, come on.
I hit that $400 pack earlier.
They must have another one.
There were so many ghost cards.
The ghost cards must be worth millions of dollars!
Save for the upgraded- Oh my god!
Oh my god!
You need deodorant, mister!
Sir, get over back here!
Get back over here!
Get back over here.
Get clean.
I will use this entire can until you're okay!
I-
It's never too late for deodorant.
I don't know what you're talking about.
It's never too late.
Okay.
Let's see.
$1.
Oh my god, you bought so many rare cards.
This loser doesn't know it's all in the boxes.
$27.
Okay, I can put another card in here.
Nice, alright.
Is there any other?
Oh, that one just sold.
That means I can put another one.
Alright.
It's time.
It's time for more cards.
Wait, do I have?
Okay, yeah.
I just need $10 more so I can buy dice for you guys.
But that's it.
That's all I'm gonna do.
Maybe I should just make this store a figure store instead of a card game store.
So then I can keep all the cards to myself.
Maybe I should...
Maybe I should make this a dice store.
So I can use it to afford my trading card.
Oh no, give me a sec.
Where do I put this?
There has to be...
Put these in here.
Okay.
I need to look at it.
Where is that $400?
Oh my god!
Look at this card!
$400!
Oh my god.
I'm gonna sell it right now.
They bought the other $400.
This lady bought the other $400.
She bought the other $400.
Lady, are you sure I can't tempt you with this card too?
Oh!
Look at that.
She bought...
Wait, I need to add .99.
Oh my god!
Imagine all the...
I can buy so many.
I can...
Oh my god, oh my god.
Wait, wait.
Where's my phone?
Okay, we're gonna buy...
First, we're gonna buy the plushy license first.
And then...
And then we'll buy...
Oh, okay.
We got the plushy license.
Wait, can I afford the plushies?
Okay.
Oh, I can!
I think I just made enough.
No!
I literally need $0.76.
Thank you.
That is what I needed.
That is what I...
Guys, I still have enough time!
Guys, look!
Look at my phone, guys.
Look at it right now.
Four days.
I still have four days, guys.
I still have four days.
It's five.
This is much more important, chat.
This is much more important.
We'll buy...
Add this to the cart.
And then...
We can finally sell other stuff now.
We can finally...
We can finally sell other things.
Okay, there you go.
And then we have card sleeves, too.
And we'll put it at the bottom rack.
We can finally afford to sell other things.
It's fine.
We have...
Okay.
There we go.
Into the corner it goes.
Oh, he also bought cards.
Yeah, that's fine.
Let's see.
Okay, prices.
Market price.
10%.
There we go.
And then, market price.
10%.
Wait, market price.
3 dollars.
There we go.
See?
We're making money.
This is fine.
I told you, guys.
I told you.
No, no, no, no, guys.
No, no.
It's 200 dollars, guys.
Rent is only 200 dollars.
It's literally 200 dollars.
I can afford it.
It'll be fine.
Oh, see?
Look at that.
64 dollars already.
And you know what that means.
Oh, I can save up.
I can buy the rare boxes.
These don't matter anymore.
These won't matter when I have the rare boxes.
Wait.
600 and 500 dollars is a four pack.
So now all I need to do is just save up 500 dollars so I can buy the rare boxes.
And then I can sell the basic boxes.
Because these don't fucking matter anymore.
Guys, and then I can sell the basic boxes because the rare boxes are even better.
Oh my god.
And then I can get cards that might be worth 600 dollars, chat.
Imagine I can get the 600 dollar pack.
Just imagine.
Oh my god.
Guys, it's okay.
I have four more days.
I have four more days to pay for rent.
It's okay.
I have four more days.
I can pay for four more days left.
It's okay.
I'll just be a plushy store.
I'll just be a plushy store to fund my TCG hobby.
That's it.
Okay, I'm kicking you out.
Okay, nice.
How do I change the name of my store?
I want...
No, I only pull cards in the day.
I only...
Guys, you don't understand.
I can only pull cards during the day.
Alright,
come on.
You just came in here to look at my sleeve.
I can't.
I need to pull cards.
I need to...
How do I change the name of my store, chat?
Guys, how do I change the name of my store?
I'm rebranding.
Escape?
Is this settings?
No.
How do I...
I need to change... I need to change the name of my store.
You need to pay...
I need to rebrand.
Guys, I need to rebrand my store.
How do I...
Okay, store upgrade.
I don't need to upgrade my store.
My store is perfect as it is.
You can't rebrand...
How am I supposed to rebrand my store if I can't change the name?
How would they know I'm not a plushy store anymore?
I'm...
I'm not a card store anymore.
I'm here to sell plushies.
That's where the money is.
Oh, whoops.
Not that.
85.
91.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Get out of here.
Be clean.
That's right.
And then I'll make sure to resell it again.
Alright, let's see.
32.
.09 Alright, what do you have?
Oh, see, look at that!
The plushies are making so much money!
Look at that!
Okay, we gotta put this card down.
What do I need?
Okay, I need more basic packs.
Okay, I need to buy this.
And...
this.
I fucked up.
It's fine.
And then...
we'll make it back with plushies.
It's okay.
We'll make it back with... what is he just T-man pose?
I still have this.
It's okay.
It's fine.
I still have this.
I can't believe I started working.
.
I'm not here to work.
I'm here for my passion.
This is where my true passion is.
Come on.
Come on, I didn't...
I didn't open for a while.
Come on.
Where is it?
It should have stockpiled.
They should have stockpiled!
You won.
Okay.
$6, that's fine.
Alright, we're gonna...
put that in here.
There we go.
Where is... Okay.
Are the card sleeves too expensive?
Why is it too expensive?
Okay.
2.50.
That's the lowest I'll go.
You gotta protect your cards somewhere.
Like, don't think I don't know.
You gotta protect those cards.
Okay.
Fuck, you might as well...
I'm gonna rip that card in half right now.
You guys don't believe me.
Watch this.
That's where the $100 card went.
Wow...
Anything under $500 is nothing, Timmy.
It's not...
Oh...
Dedication to the... Doki, no!
No!
The immersion is so real.
Not the blue eyes white dragon, no!
She's... at least Kaiba was passionate about every card!
64.18 Look at that, my plushies are fucking going crazy right now.
I knew the plushies were the right investment in the end.
I fucking knew it.
Okay.
No, Kaiba would never rip the cards.
I would.
Kaiba was a pussy.
Kaiba would never rip up every card.
He did rip cards, but he didn't go all the way.
He...
He didn't go all the way.
He could have committed, but no, he had to start having feelings.
He started caring about his fucking little brother.
He started a lie to him.
Alright, this is the last one.
There's another one.
And then there is a card here.
And then I have four.
Okay, so...
Five.
Okay so...
I'm pretty sure I won that.
Okay.
Okay, so...
I don't even care who's card it belongs to.
Even if it belongs to me, if you're a weak card, I'm gonna keep ripping.
I'm gonna keep ripping those cards.
That's fucking weak.
Can't even rip your own cards.
Alright.
She's gotten mad with power.
It's fine.
Okay.
We must hit another 500.
That's so trash.
That's so fucking trash.
Why did you waste- Fuck off.
Only $383?
Are you serious?
Only 300- You know what I'm gonna do with that card?
You know what I'm gonna do with that $383?
Oh, you know what I'm gonna do, chat?
Give me a sec.
Let me open the other pack.
Let me open my other packs first.
Before I show you what I'll do.
Wait, let me- Give me a sec.
I actually have customers.
Give me- I have to do this dumb shit.
I have to fucking do my job, apparently.
Okay.
There we go.
Uh, okay.
Okay.
That's enough.
This is what I'm gonna do.
I can't even- I can't even put it in the trash.
No!
If I could, I would have actually thrown that card away.
That's like- That's red money dookie!
Stop!
This game is a coward.
This game is weak.
It won't let me throw away fucking garbage.
I should be legally allowed to throw away fucking garbage cards.
She has become more spoiled than that now.
Someone has to stop her.
Thank you for getting to rehab now.
Thank you for the super chat, MrBrokenPond.
Thank you, thank you.
Let's see, $18.
Can't be allowed to put it in my fucking store.
Fucking disgusting!
Can't be allowed to put this disgusting card in my fucking store.
$421?
Alright,
let's see.
One, two, three.
Point one, two.
Alright, oh shit.
Oh my god, I don't have- Okay.
It's okay, I can afford it now.
Where is it?
Oh, I'll put this here for now.
Oh, it's okay, he left.
It's okay, he left.
I'll put this here too.
And then- Oh, okay.
I'll just put this here because this has remaining stock.
And then I'll put this here.
Uh-oh, stinky.
Sell it for a dollar out of spite.
Damn.
And you called me mad.
You called me mad with power.
Okay, box has no items in it.
Okay.
Holy shit.
I need to make sure I have enough plushies for my plushy store.
Wait, can I afford this now?
No, I can't.
I need to buy the license.
What other stuff?
Oh, I can buy dice now, right?
It's $218.
Oh yeah, I can.
Alright.
Maybe I'll make more prof money.
Oh, wait.
Come on, get clean.
Get clean.
If you're gonna be playing cards, you gotta make sure you're clean like the rest of us.
That's space.
Okay, wait.
I'll put this here.
And now I have space for my dice store.
Because this is now a dice store, guys.
Okay.
There we go.
We're fine.
Okay, give me my money.
And then back to card opening.
Oh my god, we're almost level 10 and then everything can be automated.
And I can truly invest in what I actually love.
It's alright.
The child doesn't need to be paid until six days.
I'll just pay the child in store credit.
It's fine.
And as long as the child doesn't go near my fucking corner, Sash, he'll be okay.
Okay, I just need like...
I just need $500 so I can buy the rare boxes.
And then like when I buy the rare boxes, I can sell the basic bitch boxes.
And then I'm gonna make thousands of dollars off the rare boxes.
That's where the money comes in, guys.
You don't understand.
That's where the big ticket items are.
That's the big ticket items.
Right there.
It's okay, guys.
Do not worry.
We're gonna...
We're gonna make it all back.
Right here.
We're gonna make it all back, chat.
The last day.
The last day is where it matters.
We still have three days, guys.
We have three days.
We can do this.
We have...
We have three days.
It's fine.
It's so fine.
We have three days, guys.
Oh, and then I can get more space here.
Three days is where it's at.
Come on, guys.
Oh, are you looking at my $400 card?
Are you like...
We can make it all back.
It's so easy.
Three days.
Yeah.
Three days may as well be two weeks.
I told you.
Is this game actually fun or just your average sim store game?
It's all right.
Like...
Okay.
Nice.
All right.
Thank you for the...
Free chat.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
All right.
Yeah.
I can stop whenever I want.
I can...
All right, guys.
9 PM.
It's almost there.
It's all right.
Spends $500.
It's almost there.
Get out.
It's 9.
The clock stopped.
It stopped exactly at 9.
Now leave.
That's right.
Oh, nice.
Oh shit!
She bought dice.
I told you.
The dice market.
We're GameStop now.
20.28 28.
We stopped at exactly closing time.
Let's see.
We have...
Oh yeah!
Eventually we'll start making profit.
We're almost there at profit!
Okay.
There we go.
Am I missing anything?
Okay.
Cards, please.
We have cards to use here.
Okay.
We need $500 and we're fine.
We just need $500.
And then we'll be okay.
Alright.
No.
Rent is not due yet.
We have three more.
We have two days.
So close.
Only $440.
Tokido, please.
You know what I see when I see that $440 card?
You know what I see, chat?
I'll show you what I see when I see a $440 card.
I'll show you.
That's fucking right.
Toki, no.
Please.
Toki.
Toki, what are you doing?
Please.
Toki, what are...
What are you doing, Toki?
What are you doing?
That's right.
That's what it deserves.
Look at that.
It's 0.01 cent and nobody is buying it.
You...
Look at that.
That's how worthless this card is.
That's how fucking worthless it is.
Nobody is buying it right now.
Look at that.
This guy, look.
Oh, he's just here for dice.
He fucking didn't even look at it.
He's just here for dice.
Look at all these people.
They are just skipping over that worthless card.
Look at that.
He bought that card instead.
I mean, what did you expect?
I told you that card was fucking worthless to me.
Look at that.
He bought this card.
That's $33.
Instead of a card that's supposedly worth $400.
I told you that's a fucking worthless card.
I fucking told you, chat.
I told you nobody loves it.
It's just a fucking paperweight.
It doesn't deserve anything.
Back to card opening.
Back to what I'm truly passionate about.
All right.
Come on.
$500 Roonies.
That's what I need.
Not the Exodia.
Back to the street.
This is it.
Bye.
Come on.
Where is it?
There has to be...
There has to be a $500 card.
It's still not sold yet?
How is it...
It's actually still not sold yet.
It's still just sitting there.
It's literally just sitting there unsold and unloved.
Because that's what it deserved.
I told you.
They know...
Yeah, exactly.
They know it's garbage.
They fucking know.
They think it's fake.
Out of all the other cards that are like reasonably priced.
They're like, why is there a 0.01 set?
She put the card in the wrong place.
She put the used receipt in it.
They're like, there's no way.
There's no way.
That card is just one cent.
Like, is that...
Is that an April Fool's prank?
I have never been so salty over a cake.
Oh my god.
It finally sold.
It is the guy that's stinky.
Of course.
Of course, Eva.
He's going to resell it.
He's like, he's like, he's like this card shop owner from down the street.
And he knows my dark history.
He knows my secret.
He knows this isn't a joke anymore.
He's going to sell it in his store for the actual price.
All right.
Okay.
Let's see, $57.
0.
Oh my god, that's a lot!
What are you going to do with all that dice, my dude?
Oh my god.
This is it.
Oh my god, thank God.
Okay.
I just need a hundred dollars.
Guys, this is it.
And then I can finally get rid of the fucking peasant boxes.
I can finally get rid of these peasant boxes.
These boxes don't give me the same thrill anymore.
That's right, you only open packs to sell cards.
Exactly!
It's a long-term investment chat!
I need to pay off my loans!
Guys...
If only we had a card to cover...
Guys, it's okay.
We're gonna get $500.
It's gonna save us on the last day.
That $500 is gonna save us on the last day.
We're gonna get somebody that's gonna buy the $500.
Guys, just believe.
Just believe, guys.
It's gonna happen.
$21?
Come on.
I have a $500 card right there.
Oh, wait.
Alright, 10%.
Okay, I sold this before.
I was like, wait a minute.
I have like three of them.
I have like three of that fucking card right there.
Wait, I think I almost...
Wait.
Okay, leave.
Okay, good.
Okay, now...
Whoops.
Good, I kicked them out.
That's what I wanted.
By kicking them out, I can finally...
I can finally buy what I'm truly passionate about.
I stopped their game mid-game.
Just like that.
Oh, my.
Get these peasant boxes out of here.
Get these peasant basic cards out of here.
I don't need this anymore.
Wait, what is this?
Oh, it's these.
Okay.
The box corner.
No, this is precious.
And then I gotta...
Okay, get these basic-ass cards out of here.
Wait, what is this?
Oh, they're these cards.
Okay.
Alright.
Here you go.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I can't mix them.
Can't mix trash with my actual good shit.
Get this trash out of here.
Get it out of here.
Ugh, disgusting.
Ugh!
Alright, that's...
That's my good box right here.
That's all the...
That's where my good boxes go.
Okay, let's see.
Idiot.
There we go.
Oh, shit.
I need to buy more of those plushies.
Idiot.
Two...
Oh.
Okay.
I need to buy dice and the plushies.
Give me a sec.
Sorry, I keep going outside to buy this because I have...
I need better reception.
I go outside because I need better reception, guys.
Alright, and then dice.
Oh, I need 300?
What the fuck?
How much?
Oh, yeah.
The dice is like 282.
I forgot about that.
Seven dollars and 91 cent.
Here we go.
Wait, how...
When...
It's a plushy store.
Yeah!
I have two days.
That's fine.
Two days is more than enough day.
Wait, I have dice still?
Wait, no.
This is garbage.
Garbage.
Garbage corner.
Wait, I do?
This?
Which one is it?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, I do have more.
Nice.
Okay.
That's good.
I do have more space.
Okay.
And then we're going to pop...
Put another card in here.
Oh, shit.
14 dollars.
There we go.
Oh, he bought dice too!
Five, six...
Oh, shit.
Okay, nice.
Okay, now my true passion.
Now I finally have time.
Wait, how much is it to hire an employee?
No.
$500 processing fee?
I need $500 to hire Zett Cole?
Bro, you work in high...
You're in high school!
Why the fuck do I need $500 deposit for you?
Why?
Oh, it doesn't matter.
This is rare.
This is the true passion.
Right here.
Finally.
Finally, I can buy something I truly...
Cole is awful.
I can't believe Cole would like, scam me like this!
For one day!
I need to pay Cole $500!
Nothing.
That's nothing to me.
It should be $500 of store credit!
That's what it should be!
Alright, 98 cents.
Okay.
What do I...
Wait, I need to buy...
I need $392, so...
Oh wait, no.
I have enough plush.
I have enough, so I can just...
I can just...
I don't need dice, actually.
I just need plushies.
From my plushy store.
Guys, somebody will buy, like, the last...
Guys, trust me.
This is... This will work, guys.
Trust me.
See?
They're buying my rare packs.
Guys, tomorrow...
Tomorrow's where I'm gonna make it big, guys.
Tomorrow, I'll...
I'll be able to pay my bills.
Tomorrow, all these cards!
Will be sold, chat.
Tomorrow.
It's gonna be tomorrow.
Where things...
Where the magic happens.
Guys...
Tomorrow is where the magic happens!
You don't under...
Just trust...
Trust the process!
Trust the process, chat.
I'll make, like, $500 tomorrow.
Tomorrow!
Tomorrow, we'll discover...
Tomorrow is where we're gonna hit it big!
Let's see.
33.02.
Okay, guys.
Guys.
Leave.
I need to start tomorrow.
I need to...
I need you to leave.
You guys still bought those packs.
You might say they're expensive, but you didn't quit.
You didn't fucking quit.
Alright.
This is it.
This is where the magic happens.
Right here, chat.
This is exactly when my luck turns around.
Right here.
For these cards.
No, I'm not talking about the store.
I'm talking about my card luck.
This is where the luck turns around right here.
This is where my luck will turn around.
For my cards.
Here it is.
We're gonna grab it.
We're gonna get that.
We're gonna get that full art.
Exactly!
Exactly, Mr. ReapN.
This is where we get the full art.
The full art that's worth a thousand dollars.
This is it.
Today's the day.
We're gonna get that thousand dollar card.
And just to be sure.
Just to be sure.
I'm gonna buy another box.
Just to be sure I actually hit that.
I just gotta be sure.
Don't worry.
I'm gonna make... Don't worry.
I'll have enough for bills.
Today's the last day.
It'll be fine.
It's my corner.
My plushies... My plushie business is going great, if you're wondering.
Oh, that's not it.
My plushie store is doing absolutely wonderful.
Please, you haven't eaten and showered in days!
You don't understand.
You don't understand my passion.
If you cared about me, you wouldn't want me to get that full art!
If you actually cared about me!
The plushie store is doing fine.
The cards are, however...
This is it.
This is where my luck changes.
Right here.
I will miss the for-profit.
I'll miss when she cared about us making money.
Not the cards.
Not...
Come on.
There has to be... has to be one of them.
Where is it?
It's okay.
We can make it back.
We can make it back so easily.
Fourteen... Fourteen point twenty-one.
I have to do like this.
Three...
One, two, three, four, five, six.
Oh, I could have just... I could have...
Three, two... Oh, wait.
Okay.
Oh my god!
That's enough!
To buy another box of cards.
To buy two boxes of cards.
That's just enough.
That's...
Guys, it's only 11 a.m.
I have plenty of time.
Guys, I have so much time.
You don't understand.
I have so much time.
It's okay.
There's so much time.
Get that art out of here.
If it's not holographic full art, it's nothing to me.
It's fucking nothing.
It might as well be two weeks.
Exactly.
Come on.
It's okay.
That thousand dollar card, we're gonna hit it right here.
Just don't listen to those non-believers.
Exactly.
You don't believe.
Get out.
Get clean.
That's right.
Even when I'm opening boxes, I have my friends.
Even when opening boxes, I still know what's up.
I still get ready to spray.
Okay.
Nice.
10, 13, 50, 60, 91.
There you go.
Okay.
How many cards sold?
We'll put that here.
Put that here.
Then we'll put that here.
Okay.
Nice.
And then we'll sell this one.
All right.
Oh, shit.
She bought three boxes.
Oh, my God.
That's enough.
That's just enough.
To buy more.
Wait.
That's just enough.
That's literally just enough.
Oh, wait.
No, I need $100 left.
Okay.
It's a higher call.
No, it's okay.
I can buy one more.
Just one more.
Guys, this box.
This is it.
This is the box.
This is the box where I'm going to get that $1,000 card.
This is it.
Guys, this is that box.
Just one more.
Guys, I have seven more hours.
It's fine.
Seven more hours, chat.
Seven more hours.
I can keep buying cards for seven more hours.
Trust it.
Trust the process.
Just seven more hours.
That's a lot.
Exactly.
That's so many hours, chat.
That's so many hours to open packs.
Right here.
Trust it.
I'm going to get $1,000.
And then we don't have to worry about bills for the rest of our lives.
Not even $500.
Get that card away from me.
I'm a $500 gal.
I'm in the red money.
Might as well be trash.
Guys, don't make me go on eBay and buy a $500 Pokemon card and then rip it in half.
No, buy a $447 equivalent Pokemon card and then I'll rip it.
Doki, no.
This is a simulation, Doki.
Don't confuse it with the real life.
Doki, you're in a video game.
Don't confuse it with real life.
Doki.
Oh, that's enough.
That's enough.
Just enough to hire Cole.
Let's go.
Hire Cole and buy another box.
Buy another box.
Let's go.
Oh my god.
Now that Cole works here.
Where's Cole?
Where is he?
Where the fuck is Cole?
Where is this teenager I hired?
Is that him?
Customers!
Doki, he literally just got out of school.
Get over there right now, Cole!
Fucking
cards!
Why are you fucking exclamation pointing me right now?
I'm here to open cards!
Get it together, Cole!
Get your...
Cole,
get your fucking ass in my store.
I mean, I'm too busy opening cards.
Accept his quest.
His little fucking side quest right here.
I didn't train this child?
Cole, please.
We have three more hours left in my store.
Cole, I need you to do your work.
Okay, man counters.
No, don't you dare touch my stock.
Don't you fucking dare touch this stock.
Okay, I need to put another card down.
All right.
I told you.
I told you, guys.
I fucking told you.
Now all I can...
Now all I can do is do what I...
Now this is the entire stream.
Now the real stream starts, chat.
This is the real stream.
We made it.
Also, I realize like three hours has passed now.
But like I hope the volume...
The game...
I hope the game volume wasn't too loud.
I know...
I know I shouldn't have asked earlier.
But I was very committed.
Oh, shit.
Sorry.
Guys, my phone was ringing and I'm too busy.
I...
The BGM was kind of loud.
You told me now.
Oh, no.
For three hours.
Oh, my God.
Oh, it was loud.
I can't...
Sorry, I have a voicemail playing right now.
I did not...
I'm not taking the phone call.
Sorry,
there's a voicemail that's going on right now.
But I didn't take the call because this is much more important.
Guys!
I knew it.
You don't stop.
Guys, how long is this fucking voicemail?
It's still...
This guy is still voicemailing.
Is it done yet?
Oh, it's done.
Okay.
Okay, now I'm back.
I told you.
I fucking told...
$700 right here.
And we still have one more spray left.
I told you.
I fucking told you.
None of you.
None of you believed in me.
I still have...
I still have time to do one more card opening.
I still have time.
Guys, I still have time.
I still have time to do one more card opening before I pay rent.
Guys.
No, no, no.
I still have time.
Guys, no, no, no.
I still...
I didn't change my sound setting, but I still have time.
I...
I know I should be changing my sound, but like I still have time.
It's...
I still have time.
It's okay.
10 more seconds.
10 seconds.
It's okay.
I told you.
Bam.
Not even close.
Not even fucking close.
You know what?
That's beating the game.
You didn't believe in me, chat.
I told you to trust the process.
And look at that.
Look at that.
Look at that, my sexy x-rare foil.
You didn't believe.
Wouldn't it be funny if you can actually throw the cards?
I'll...
I'll throw that.
All right.
Now...
Now that I opened a $700 card, I think I can retire.
I think...
I'm ready.
Now I'm ready to retire.
I'm ready to...
I already peaked, so I'm ready to call it there.
Don't keep going to the list.
I can't go.
I was never almost homeless.
I trusted the process.
I knew what's up.
I knew that I was going to make it big.
I knew it.
I trusted.
But you didn't get that $1,000.
All right.
You know what?
All right, bet.
Bet.
Okay, give me a sec.
I'm opening the game again.
Bet.
All right.
Give me a sec.
I'm opening the game again.
I'm opening that game again.
You think we won't?
You want to fucking bet we won't?
Don't worry, guys.
Don't worry.
I will open the rest of those packs.
I'm back.
I'm back to not rigged 100%.
This corner, this box corner of stuff I have right here.
You want to bet we won't get this?
All right, here we go.
All right, wait.
Do we actually need to turn down the sound?
I actually don't know if people were trolling.
All right.
This is it.
We're going to open that $1,000 card right here.
It's in here.
We're going to turn this car around.
We're going to get that $1,000 card.
We're going to...
Right here.
This is where...
Don't talk to me.
We're here for the $1,000 card.
This is it.
This has to be it.
We have so many boxes.
We actually...
We're not even going to open the store.
All these people are like, when will the store open?
I'm just out here opening the card.
The Canva stream.
I don't even need to purchase new boxes, chat.
I don't even need to purchase new boxes because I know...
I know that in that box is where it is.
In that box is that...
In all those boxes that I have right now, it will be $1,000.
I can feel it.
I can fucking feel it.
It's got to be in here.
I have like five.
I have like 20 of these.
I think I have like at least 30 booster packs in the corner.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure I have 30.
I have 30 booster packs in that fucking corner there.
It's going to be in it.
There's a 15K card.
What's the most expensive card you can pull, chat?
God, I don't care about that.
Don't give me a fucking sound effect for something that weak.
All right, this is it.
Open all the cards in the store.
My minimum wage worker is just here waiting.
He's just like, please, please.
Please, manager, please.
The time has stopped because...
Oh, the first one off the bat.
Too bad it's only $20 though.
Let him work.
He's like, please, please, manager.
Please, time stopped.
I thought I've been standing there for two hours, but it's still 8 a.m.
All right.
There has to be a thousand.
We must get a thousand dollars.
Thousand dollars or bust.
Thousand dollars or bust right here.
Where's my others?
Where is it?
Okay, I knew there's more.
I knew there's more.
No, we're not opening the store.
We don't need that money right now.
We don't need it.
We need that thousand dollar card.
Yeah, time's not moving, so he's not getting paid exactly.
Come on.
Where is it?
I don't have a problem.
It has to be in this pack.
It has to be in it.
As long as I don't open the store, time has stopped.
I control the store.
I control the world's time.
The world revolves around this Tetramon store.
$8?
God, that's like...
That's like money for ants.
Even ants don't want that card.
What am I going to do with an $8 worth of cards?
0.18.
Come on.
That thousand dollars.
I don't think she's going to the bank today.
I still have three more hours of closing time.
There's plenty of time.
There's still three more hours.
There's still three more hours of...
There's still three more hours, chat.
I still have three more hours left before the bank closed.
That's plenty of time.
That's so much time.
That's...
There's so much time.
We're fine.
I have three more hours.
And if I have two more hours, that's still plenty of time.
Two more hours of bank time.
That's so much time.
Okay.
Come on.
There has to be...
Wait, is that the last one?
It's okay.
I still have like two more boxes.
I still have like...
I still have four more boxes.
How much did I buy?
Oh my God.
Three hours is a lot.
It's like a week.
It's still a week.
Three hours is like a week worth of time, guys.
That's like a week's worth.
This is it.
I bet you it's going to be the last box.
It's going to be the last box.
It has to be.
I should have bought four boxes.
No, because I don't need to because I know.
I know the winning pack.
The winning card is all is in there.
It's in there.
You get the one...
You can't get the 1K card in this box.
Wait, does the 1K card exist?
Does it exist in the rare packs?
Or is it just like...
Is it like a really low chance to appear?
I need to know.
It only...
It should...
It exists in the rare packs?
It exists in this pack?
It's in the purple, no?
Wait.
It does...
Oh, it does?
Okay, we just keep going.
I knew it.
We don't stop.
We just keep going.
We just have to keep going.
We just...
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
We can just keep going.
I always believe.
As long as you don't stop.
As long as...
As long as we don't stop, guys.
Never let the doubters get you.
Never let the doubters win.
It has to be in here.
It has to be.
There's so many cards.
It has to be in one of them.
Never quit.
Never surrender, chat.
She's behind us.
If you don't stop, it will happen.
You never quit.
The probability rises higher.
The more you...
The more you unpack the cards, the higher the probability rate.
Wait.
Think about that, chat.
Have you ever thought about that?
Come on.
The probability goes higher.
The more packs you buy, your luck raises higher.
Because eventually you hit it big.
That's why you don't quit.
That's why.
That's not how statistics work.
Oh, yeah.
Where's your math degree?
Wait.
I only...
I only listen to somebody who has a master's degree in statistics.
It's fine.
We still have another box.
We still have another one.
Don't go into the Capricorn.
Where's yours?
Exactly.
None of us.
Yeah, exactly.
So what you say doesn't matter because you don't have the math degree.
What I say matters because this is my stream.
Why would I lie to my chat?
I have a reputation... reputation to uphold.
Exactly.
The 0.0001% ain't gonna hit itself.
Guys, it'll be so worth it.
It's gonna be...
It's gonna be so worth it when we hit the jackpot.
It's gonna be so worth it, guys.
This is a box of nothing.
Why is there a box of nothing?
Oh my god.
We have two boxes left.
This is it.
It has to be in this one.
The last two boxes.
It has to be.
This is the streamer moment.
This is the streamer moment, chat.
Right here.
It's a 0% chance.
Yes, exactly.
It's a 0% chance if you don't try.
And by trying, I already raised it to at least 50%.
That's idiot.
Come on.
Give me that 1K.
That 1K card.
Come on.
I know you're alive.
This is the last box, guys.
This is it.
The last box right here.
I didn't answer my phone for this.
I don't know what phone call I just got 30 minutes ago.
But I need a thousand dollars.
Alright, this is it.
Come on.
Maybe it'll be here.
I don't know how many packs I have left.
But maybe it'll be this one.
Maybe it's the next pack.
It has to be the next pack.
Wait, maybe it's in...
Maybe it's in these.
It has to be in these.
Right?
Maybe...
Maybe it's in this one.
No, guys.
It's totally in this.
It's in these, guys.
No, this is my own pack.
I made my own pack, guys.
I made my own box.
Guys, I made my own box.
It has to be in one of these.
It has to be.
I swear, guys.
Toki, stop.
Stop.
These are the customers' booster packs, Toki.
Toki, that's the customers' booster packs, Toki.
What happened to not using them?
But whatever.
Guys, I think it's in them booster packs.
I think it's actually in the booster packs, guys.
I think...
Guys, I made my own pack.
I made my own box.
Guys, I made my own box, guys.
Guys, I don't think this is about the money anymore.
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Don't worry.
It's in here.
Never get high on your own supply.
No, it's here.
It has to be.
It has to be here.
Oh, my God.
But the customers, I knew it.
They were trying to get my...
They were trying to scam me.
I fucking knew it.
I knew those customers were trying to scam me.
I knew it.
I knew they were all supposed to be in here.
It has to be here.
Whoa.
What is that?
Guys, it's a divine intervention.
Alright, guys, I gotta call it down.
Thank you, everybody, for watching.
I'll give you a...
I think it's...
I think that's what I was getting called.
I think it's like a false alarm.
Yeah, it's a fire alarm test.
I can't believe...
Okay, but last card.
Let's back.
Okay, I'm gonna head off now.
As always, everybody stay hydrated.
Pause your check.
Get up and move around.
Get down.
Hear that blood flowing?
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.